Do you get chills when you hear the choral from Beethoven's 9th Symphony? Does Samuel Barber's adagio for strings make you tear up? Are there songs that transport you to another time, whether it's music by the Beatles or the police or Nirvana? Does some music make you happy and want to dance? For many of us, music taps into our deepest emotions and memories, and yet, for others, music is just meh. Over the last several decades, psychologists and other research,
当你听到贝多芬第九交响曲的合唱时，你会感到战栗吗？塞缪尔·巴伯的《弦乐柔板》会让你热泪盈眶吗？有没有哪首歌能把你带回另一个时代，无论是披头士、警察乐队还是涅槃乐队的音乐？有些音乐是否让你感到快乐并想跳舞？对我们许多人来说，音乐触动了我们最深的情感和记忆，然而，对另一些人来说，音乐却平平无奇。在过去的几十年里，心理学家和其他研究人员，
researchers have begun to explore why music affects us so profoundly. What happens in the brain when we listen to music or when we sing or play an instrument? Why does some music give us goosebumps while other pieces leave us cold? On the other hand, why do a small number of people experience almost no emotional response to music at all? And what can studying music and the brain teach us about broader questions of perception, memory, language, and cognition? Welcome to Speaking of Psychology, the flagship podcast of the American Psychological Association that examines the links between psychological science and everyday life. I'm Kim Mills. My guest today is Dr. Robert Zatore, a professor in the Department of Neurology and Neurosurgery at McGill University, who holds a Canada
研究人员已经开始探索为什么音乐对我们有如此深远的影响。当我们听音乐、唱歌或演奏乐器时，大脑中发生了什么？为什么有些音乐让我们起鸡皮疙瘩，而另一些作品却让我们无动于衷？另一方面，为什么极少数人对音乐几乎没有任何情感反应？研究音乐和大脑能教会我们关于感知、记忆、语言和认知等更广泛问题的什么知识？欢迎收听《心理学谈话》，这是美国心理学会的旗舰播客，旨在探讨心理科学与日常生活之间的联系。我是金·米尔斯。我今天的嘉宾是麦吉尔大学神经学和神经外科系教授罗伯特·扎托雷博士，他担任加拿大
research chair in auditorial cognitive neuroscience at the Montreal Neurological Institute. For decades, he's been a pioneer in the neuroscience of music, studying how the brain processes music, speech and sound, and why music can evoke such powerful emotional experiences. His research has helped to explain how the brain's auditory and reward systems work together to create musical pleasure. He's examined topics ranging from musical anhedonia, the inability to derive pleasure from music, to the relationship between music and language. He's author of more than 350 scientific research papers as well as the book, From Perception to Pleasure, the neuroscience of music and why we love it.
蒙特利尔神经学研究所听觉认知神经科学研究主席。几十年来，他一直是音乐神经科学领域的先驱，研究大脑如何处理音乐、语言和声音，以及为什么音乐能唤起如此强大的情感体验。他的研究有助于解释大脑的听觉和奖励系统如何共同作用以产生音乐愉悦感。他研究的主题范围广泛，从音乐快感缺失（即无法从音乐中获得快乐）到音乐与语言之间的关系。他撰写了超过350篇科学研究论文，以及《从感知到愉悦：音乐的神经科学以及我们为何热爱它》一书。
Dr. Zaturi, thank you for joining me today. Thank you very much for having me, Kim. Let's start with a big picture question. I read in a previous interview that you said, music touches every cognitive function there is. Can you talk about that? How does music touch so many different aspects of human cognition? Part of the reason I say that is when people ask me,
扎托雷博士，感谢您今天接受我的采访。非常感谢您的邀请，金。让我们从一个宏观的问题开始。我在之前的一次采访中读到您说过，音乐触及了人类所有的认知功能。您能谈谈这一点吗？音乐是如何触及人类认知的这么多不同方面的？我之所以这么说，部分原因是当人们问我时，
well, you know, what's the value of studying music, scientifically, I often like to point out that music is not merely a pattern of sounds. It is that, of course, but that's just a start. And so we can use music to understand the auditory system. Absolutely. That's a key feature. But at the same time, music engages many, many other functions. So if you consider, for example, an everyday situation, you're, waiting for an elevator and somebody walks by and they're whistling a tune. And you recognize the tune, even though you have never heard it being whistled before. You know what it is.
嗯，你知道，从科学角度研究音乐有什么价值？我经常指出，音乐不仅仅是一种声音模式。当然它是，但这只是开始。因此，我们可以利用音乐来理解听觉系统。绝对是这样。这是一个关键特征。但与此同时，音乐还涉及许多许多其他功能。所以，如果你考虑一个日常情况，比如你在等电梯，有人走过，他们正在吹口哨。即使你以前从未听过这首曲子被吹出来，你也能认出它。你知道那是什么。
You immediately think of the fact that it was being played last summer when you were at the beach with your best friend that you hadn't seen for a while. This brings back memories. at the same time you start to tap your foot as you imagine the music. So even though the music is gone, the person walked by, you can still actually hear it in your mind's ear. As you do so, you might tap your foot, you might sway to the rhythm of the music,
你立刻会想到，去年夏天你和一位许久未见的好友在海滩上时，这首歌正在播放。这勾起了回忆。与此同时，当你想象音乐时，你开始用脚打拍子。所以即使音乐已经消失，那个人已经走过，你仍然可以在脑海中听到它。当你这样做时，你可能会用脚打拍子，可能会随着音乐的节奏摇摆，
engaging your motor system, and it may also just be a very pleasurable experience. You may actually find that you're in a better mood, just because you were thinking of that music. So just think of the list of cognitive operations that went through there. There's some kind of auditory processing, there's some engagement with a motor system, there's an engagement with a memory system, there's an affective response, hedonic response, an emotional response, etc. So this is why I like
调动你的运动系统，这可能也只是一种非常愉快的体验。你甚至可能发现自己的心情变好了，仅仅因为你在想那段音乐。所以，想想刚才提到的那一连串认知操作。有某种听觉处理，有与运动系统的某种互动，有与记忆系统的互动，有情感反应、享乐反应、情绪反应等等。这就是为什么我喜欢
to say, you know, it engages the whole brain in the sense that it is a very complex type of human activity that doesn't stop just at the level of sound, but it is really, I think, remarkably interesting from that perspective because it is so rich. Now, you found in your research that there's a link between music and pleasure that can be traced to the brain's reward system. How does that work? What's happening in the brain when we're enjoying listening to music? Yeah, so this is a very, very important part of our research. For years, psychologists and physiologists had studied the so-called reward system. This is a series of structures in the brain that are known to be very important for reward.
说，你知道，它调动了整个大脑，因为它是一种非常复杂的人类活动，不仅仅停留在声音层面。从这个角度来看，我认为它确实非常有趣，因为它太丰富了。现在，您在研究中发现音乐与愉悦感之间存在联系，可以追溯到大脑的奖励系统。这是如何运作的？当我们享受听音乐时，大脑中发生了什么？是的，这是我们研究中非常、非常重要的一部分。多年来，心理学家和生理学家一直在研究所谓的奖励系统。这是一系列已知对奖励非常重要的大脑结构。
So what does reward mean in the classical psychology sense? It means a reinforcer. It means a stimulus that causes the best. behavior to be repeated. But there's also a hedonic part to it. So although the behaviorists didn't like to talk about that, cognitive psychologists do like to talk about emotions. And when there is a rewarding stimulus, it is typically pleasurable. You feel a sense of pleasure. It's positive in some way. And all of these sorts of effects have been traced to dopaminergic neurons in certain structures in the stratium in particular, which is a deep nucleus in the brain, as well as other
那么，在经典心理学意义上，奖励意味着什么？它意味着一种强化物。它意味着一种导致行为被重复的刺激。但它也有享乐的部分。所以，尽管行为主义者不喜欢谈论这一点，但认知心理学家确实喜欢谈论情绪。当存在奖励性刺激时，它通常是令人愉悦的。你会感到一种愉悦感。它在某种程度上是积极的。所有这些影响都已追溯到纹状体中某些结构的多巴胺能神经元，特别是纹状体，它是大脑深处的一个核团，以及其他
parts of the brain, the orbital frontal cortex and the amygdala and ventrothic mental area. There's a whole complex circuitry. Now, about 25 years ago, we discovered that music actually activates the same reward system as had been identified for other types of rewarding stimuli. So essentially there's a single reward system that responds both to primary rewards, things like food, for example, if you take a hungry animal and you measure its response to food by putting an electrode into its brain, you will see that those dopamine neurons are very active when the food is delivered. Nobody really knew, including us when we discovered it, that a completely abstract stimulus like music could also engage that system. But indeed, that is what we found using brain imaging techniques. And then a few years later, we were able to demonstrate that the response is actually driven by dopamine neurons.
大脑部分，如眶额皮质、杏仁核和腹侧被盖区。这是一个完整的复杂回路。大约25年前，我们发现音乐实际上激活了与其他类型奖励性刺激相同的奖励系统。因此，本质上存在一个单一的奖励系统，它既对初级奖励（例如食物）做出反应——如果你拿一只饥饿的动物，通过在大脑中植入电极来测量它对食物的反应，你会看到当食物送达时，那些多巴胺神经元非常活跃。没有人真正知道，包括我们在发现它时，像音乐这样完全抽象的刺激也能激活该系统。但事实上，我们利用脑成像技术发现了这一点。几年后，我们能够证明这种反应实际上是由多巴胺神经元驱动的。
We know this because we can use technology to measure dopamine response in the brain, non-invasively. We have positive transmission tomography, which is a way of measuring the chemical activity in the brain. And more recently, with some colleagues in Spain, we did some experiments where we did. We manipulated the dopamine levels pharmacologically by giving volunteers certain drugs that would either elevate or inhibit the dopamine system. And we found that indeed, music given after the administration of the dopamine precursor actually gave more pleasure. And when you gave the dopamine inhibitor, it actually resulted in less pleasure. So this links music to all of these more biologically given sorts of stimuli, and I think raises very interesting questions about, you know, how is it that our brains are able to respond to this
我们知道这一点，因为我们可以利用技术无创地测量大脑中的多巴胺反应。我们有正电子发射断层扫描，这是一种测量大脑化学活动的方法。最近，我们与西班牙的一些同事做了一些实验，我们通过给志愿者服用某些药物来药理学地操纵多巴胺水平，这些药物要么提升要么抑制多巴胺系统。我们发现，在服用多巴胺前体后给予音乐，确实产生了更多的愉悦感。而当你给予多巴胺抑制剂时，它确实导致了更少的愉悦感。因此，这不仅将音乐与所有这些生物学上给定的刺激联系起来，而且我认为还提出了非常有趣的问题，关于我们的头脑是如何能够对这种
completely abstract stimulus that we call music? And it's not just music, by the way, it's other art forms as well. And how is it that this very kind of primal survival-related mechanism is brought into play? And I think that's a topic, you know, that we're very active. pursuing we and many other laboratories around the world. So what you described just was about appreciation of music, reaction to hearing music, but what about producing music? Is there a structure in the brain that's responsible for musical comprehension? Well, there's actually a very, very tight coupling between the auditory system and the motor system. so we can see that if we measure, for example, brain oscillations in the motor part of the brain, the part that controls the muscles, and the auditory part of the brain, the part that is responsible for
我们称之为音乐的完全抽象的刺激做出反应的？顺便说一句，不仅是音乐，其他艺术形式也是如此。这种非常原始的、与生存相关的机制是如何发挥作用的？我认为这是一个我们以及世界各地许多其他实验室正在积极追求的话题。那么您刚才描述的是关于对音乐的欣赏、对听音乐的反应，但创作音乐呢？大脑中是否有负责音乐理解的结构？嗯，实际上听觉系统和运动系统之间存在非常、非常紧密的耦合。所以我们可以看到，如果我们测量，例如，大脑运动部分（控制肌肉的部分）和大脑听觉部分（负责
processing sound, we see that the oscillations are very strongly coupled. They're in phase with each other between the auditory and the motor system in a way that doesn't quite happen, for example, if you look at the visual on the motor system. So they're not as strongly coupled. bolt as they are for the auditorian motor. And we think that this means that there's a very close relationship between perceiving sounds and generating sounds. If you think about it for a moment, basically every sound that you hear is the outcome of some action.
处理声音的部分）的脑振荡，我们看到振荡是强烈耦合的。它们在听觉和运动系统之间是同相的，这与例如观察视觉和运动系统时的情况不太一样。所以它们不像听觉和运动系统那样耦合得那么紧密。我们认为这意味着感知声音和产生声音之间存在非常密切的关系。如果你仔细想想，基本上你听到的每一个声音都是某种行动的结果。
There can't be sound if no action has occurred, with some very, very slight exceptions like, I don't know, thunder. And even then there's some action in the cloud, there's some kind of interaction between the molecules. So if you have a completely static environment where nothing is changing, it'll be a silent environment. So already at level of sort of physics, there's a close link there. And if you think about it from terms of biology, many, many actions, not all,
如果没有发生任何行动，就不可能有声音，除了极少数极少数的例外，比如，我不知道，雷声。即使那样，云层中也有某种行动，分子之间有某种相互作用。所以如果你有一个完全静态的环境，没有任何变化，那将是一个寂静的环境。所以已经在物理学层面，那里就有一个紧密的联系。如果你从生物学的角度来考虑它，许多许多行动，并非全部，
but many actions produce sound, including, you know, when we speak, right? Right now, I'm moving my lips on my tongue and my larynx in a coordinated manner to produce certain types of sounds. same thing when I walk. When I walk, you hear footsteps. If I clap, you hear sounds, right? So all those sounds are the outcome of different kinds of actions. And I think if we think about it from sort of a biological perspective,
但许多行动会产生声音，包括，你知道，当我们说话时，对吧？现在，我正在以协调的方式移动我的嘴唇、舌头和喉咙来产生特定类型的声音。走路时也是一样。当我走路时，你会听到脚步声。如果我拍手，你会听到声音，对吧？所以所有这些声音都是不同行动的结果。我认为如果我们从某种生物学的角度来考虑它，
this is something that's very, very fundamental. From the first moments of life, we hear sounds that we produce ourselves, right? What's the first thing that an infant does upon emerging from the womb? It screams. If it's healthy, that's what it will do, right? So literally from the first moment, you're activating your vocal tract and producing sound. And so this, I think, is kind of a very, very basic level, is the link between movement, action and sound. And also, these things influence each other.
这是非常、非常基础的东西。从生命最初的时刻起，我们就听到自己产生的声音，对吧？婴儿从子宫里出来后做的第一件事是什么？它尖叫。如果它健康，这就是它会做的事，对吧？所以从第一刻起，你就在激活你的声道并产生声音。因此，我认为这在某种非常、非常基本的层面上，是运动、行动和声音之间的联系。而且，这些事物也会相互影响。
So if I'm playing a musical instrument or if I'm speaking, the action that I make will produce a certain sound, but if I'm playing an instrument, for example, I have a certain target in mind. The sound is supposed to be a certain note with a certain tone. So as I'm playing, let's say I'm playing a violin, as I'm drawing the bow across the strings, I'm listening to the sound.
所以如果我正在演奏乐器或者如果我正在说话，我所做的动作会产生某种声音，但如果我正在演奏乐器，例如，我心中有一个特定的目标。声音应该是带有特定音调的特定音符。所以当我演奏时，假设我正在拉小提琴，当我把琴弓拉过琴弦时，我正在听声音。
If it's not what I wanted, my auditory system will feed back to the motor system, and say, no, you have to adjust your vibrato or you have to press harder with the bow or what have you. So it's a constant interplay. The sound influences the action. The action generates the sound.
如果它不是我想要的，我的听觉系统会反馈给运动系统，说，不，你必须调整你的揉弦，或者你必须用弓按得更重，或者诸如此类。所以这是一个不断的相互作用。声音影响行动。行动产生声音。
So it's a feedback loop between the two things. And that's true. You know, for music, it's true for speech. It's true for other activities that might also generate sounds. Well, getting back to the question of, pleasure and music. There are some people, albeit not a lot, who don't get any pleasure from listening to music, the musical Anhedonia, it's called. This is something that you've studied. What causes it, and can it be overcome by somebody who doesn't get anything from music,
所以这是两者之间的反馈循环。这是真的。你知道，对于音乐，对于语言，对于其他可能产生声音的活动，这都是真的。嗯，回到关于愉悦和音乐的问题。有些人，虽然不多，但从听音乐中得不到任何快乐，这被称为音乐快感缺失。这是你研究过的问题。是什么原因导致的，对于那些从音乐中得不到任何东西，
but would like to enjoy it? Yeah, this is a very interesting phenomenon. We discovered it about 15 years ago or so, because prior to that, I mean, everyone, including us, we had the assumption, well, of course, you know, everyone loves music, right? And then we started thinking about it more seriously. And, you know, a scientist, you're supposed to question your own assumptions, right? That's supposed to be a part of science. And I have very good students, and they will often question my assumptions. That's part of their job. And, you know, I'd like to encourage them to do that. And so, you know, one of them sort of said to me, well, how do we know that everyone likes music? And I was like, oh, well, I don't know, I'm just taking it for granted.
但又想享受它的人来说，这能被克服吗？是的，这是一个非常有趣的现象。我们大约在15年前左右发现了它，因为在此之前，我的意思是，每个人，包括我们，都有一个假设，嗯，当然，你知道，每个人都喜欢音乐，对吧？然后我们开始更认真地思考它。而且，作为一名科学家，你应该质疑你自己的假设，对吧？这应该是科学的一部分。我有非常好的学生，他们经常会质疑我的假设。那是他们工作的一部分。而且，你知道，我喜欢鼓励他们这样做。所以，你知道，其中一个人对我说，嗯，我们怎么知道每个人都喜欢音乐？我当时想，哦，嗯，我不知道，我只是认为这是理所当然的。
Well, why don't we actually find out? So to make a long story short, we developed a series of questionnaires, we went out into the field, we tested, you know, a few thousand people to figure it out. And what we found, really, to my surprise, is that about something like 2% of people or so who are otherwise completely healthy, there's really nothing, you know, wrong with them. I don't refer to this as a disorder exactly, because they don't think there's anything wrong with them.
嗯，为什么我们不真正去查明呢？所以长话短说，我们开发了一系列问卷，我们进入实地，我们测试了，你知道，几千人来弄清楚它。我们真正发现的，令我惊讶的是，大约有2%左右的人，他们在其他方面完全健康，真的没有什么，你知道，他们有什么问题。我并不完全称之为一种障碍，因为他们不认为自己有什么问题。
And, you know, I think it's part of neurodiversity, actually. I don't think it should be looked on as a, you know, negative sort of thing. But these are people who report no pleasure to music, even though, importantly, they experience pleasure to everything else. And I mentioned the reward system earlier as responding to, you know, food or other pleasurable activities, including, for example, social interactions, including intellectual sort of experiences, including, of course, romantic love, sex. These are things that activate the reward system. So these people with musical and hedonia, they respond to all those
而且，你知道，我认为这实际上是神经多样性的一部分。我不认为它应该被看作是一种，你知道，消极的事情。但这些人报告说对音乐没有愉悦感，尽管重要的是，他们对其他一切事物都能体验到愉悦。我之前提到奖励系统是对，你知道，食物或其他愉快的活动做出反应，包括，例如，社交互动，包括智力方面的体验，当然也包括浪漫的爱情、性。这些是激活奖励系统的事物。所以这些患有音乐快感缺失的人，他们对所有这些
things. We tested them very specifically by having them play really kind of addictive video games that where you can win some money. And we know this activates a reward system. This is why those games are annoyingly addictive, right? And when we gave those games to these people, they, you know, sort of got hooked on it just like everyone else. But when we played music to them and we put them in a brain scanner, we noticed there was no response at all in their reward system or very, very limited.
事物都有反应。我们通过让他们玩那种你可以赢钱的、非常容易上瘾的电子游戏来专门测试他们。我们知道这会激活奖励系统。这就是为什么那些游戏令人恼火地上瘾，对吧？当我们把那些游戏给这些人时，他们，你知道，就像其他人一样迷上了它。但当我们给他们播放音乐并把他们放进脑扫描仪时，我们注意到他们的奖励系统中根本没有反应，或者非常、非常有限。
And so this is exactly in line with what they report on questionnaires. When you ask them, they say, well, of course I'd like to, you know, know, go watch a movie with my friends. And then I like to go out for a meal afterwards and maybe, you know, enjoy a few beers. And, you know, I have a boyfriend and I like to hang out with him and, you know, et cetera. These are all the normal pleasures of life. But when I'm with my friends and they say, oh, let's go to a concert, I'm always completely blank about it. And then they tell me, oh, you have to listen to this, you know, new band that just came out. And they put the music on and I'm completely flat.
所以这与他们在问卷上报告的内容完全一致。当你问他们时，他们说，嗯，当然我喜欢，你知道，去和朋友看电影。然后我喜欢之后出去吃顿饭，也许，你知道，喝几杯啤酒。而且，你知道，我有一个男朋友，我喜欢和他待在一起，而且，你知道，等等。这些都是生活中正常的快乐。但当我和朋友在一起，他们说，哦，我们去听音乐会吧，我总是对此完全没感觉。然后他们告诉我，哦，你必须听听这个，你知道，刚出的新乐队。他们放了音乐，我完全没感觉。
And I tell them, no, music just doesn't do it for me. And so this is very interesting because it means that, you know, the way that we experience music can be dissociated from the pleasure response that we talked about earlier. And when we dig further into the brains of these folks with musical and hedonia, what we observe is that the literally the connection, the white matter fibers that connect the auditory part of the brain with the reward system, that system is less robust than it normally is. That pathway is not as well-structured as it typically
我告诉他们，不，音乐对我来说就是没感觉。所以这非常有趣，因为这意味着，你知道，我们体验音乐的方式可以与我们之前谈到的愉悦反应分离开来。当我们进一步挖掘这些患有音乐快感缺失的人的大脑时，我们观察到的是，字面上连接大脑听觉部分和奖励系统的连接，即白质纤维，那个系统不如正常情况下稳健。那条通路不像通常那样结构良好。
is. And so we think this is very likely a congenital sort of effect. People usually tell us that this is something that they've had, you know, ever since they can remember. It is not a recent something that happened. And so like I mentioned, I think it's good to think of it in terms of neurodiversity. People's brains are wired in different ways. And even though most of us are really wired for music, some of us very strongly so, we call them hyperhodomics, there are some people for whom music is really not emotionally engaging. And by the way, there's nothing wrong with their auditory system either. We, of course, check for that. We test for their ability to distinguish the pitch of different tones and things like that.
所以我们认为这很可能是一种先天性的影响。人们通常告诉我们，这是他们，你知道，从记事起就有的东西。这不是最近发生的事情。所以就像我提到的，我认为从神经多样性的角度来思考它是很好的。人们的大脑以不同的方式连接。尽管我们大多数人确实是为音乐而生的，有些人甚至非常强烈，我们称他们为超享乐者，但有些人对音乐确实没有情感上的参与。顺便说一句，他们的听觉系统也没有问题。我们当然检查过这一点。我们测试了他们区分不同音调的音高和诸如此类的能力。
So it's not that they can't hear the patterns. It's just that the patterns are not especially emotionally engaging for them. And given the brain's plasticity, as we now understand it, is there a way to train yourself to appreciate music if you are an hedonic? Yeah, that's a really good question. One of my colleagues is, in fact, testing that right now. I'm skeptical that it will work because if this connection that I talked about is physically, you know, not, not as functional as normal,
所以并不是他们听不出模式。只是这些模式对他们来说并没有特别的情感参与。鉴于我们现在所理解的大脑可塑性，如果你是快感缺失者，有没有办法训练自己去欣赏音乐？是的，这是一个非常好的问题。事实上，我的一位同事现在正在测试这一点。我怀疑它是否有效，因为如果我谈到的这种连接在物理上，你知道，没有，没有像正常那样功能正常，
then I think, you know, the absence of that pathway suggests that, to me, at least, that it probably isn't something that's easy to train. But I have to keep an open mind about it because we do know that these pathways often can be enhanced with different kinds of experience. So it is possible, I don't know. We'll see. We'll know maybe in another year or two. when my colleague's study is finished.
那么我认为，你知道，那条通路的缺失向我暗示，至少，它可能不是一件容易训练的事情。但我必须对此保持开放的态度，因为我们确实知道这些通路通常可以通过不同种类的经验得到增强。所以这是可能的，我不知道。我们会看到的。也许再过一两年我们就会知道了，当我的同事的研究完成时。
I mean, many of the people we talk to with musical and Hedonia don't report it as any kind of hindrance to their lives. They say, no, my life is perfectly fine. I don't get music, but it doesn't bother me. So, you know, I think we just have to be careful about respecting, you know, how people feel about it. It's not a disorder that needs to be cured necessarily. Right, right.
我的意思是，我们交谈过的许多患有音乐快感缺失的人并不认为这是对他们生活的任何阻碍。他们说，不，我的生活非常好。我不懂音乐，但这并不困扰我。所以，你知道，我认为我们只需要小心尊重，你知道，人们对此的感受。它不一定是一种需要治愈的障碍。对，对。
Well, for a lot of people, music has an amazing ability to bring back memories. You know, a particular song might transport us back to the moment when we first heard it or to a significant event in our life. You were talking earlier about even just hearing a little bit of a snippet of somebody whistling a song could bring back a memory. Why is music such a powerful cue for autobiographical memory? Yeah, this is a topic of great interest. And there's a lot of very good research going on. right now, attempting to answer that question in some detail, especially because if we can figure out why it is, why it is the case, we might be able to develop certain applications like
嗯，对很多人来说，音乐有一种神奇的能力，能带回记忆。你知道，一首特定的歌可能会把我们带回到我们第一次听到它的时候，或者带回到我们生命中一个重要的事件。你刚才谈到即使只是听到某人吹口哨的一小段片段也能带回记忆。为什么音乐是自传体记忆的如此强大的线索？是的，这是一个非常令人感兴趣的话题。目前有很多非常好的研究正在进行，试图详细回答这个问题，特别是如果我们能弄清楚为什么它是这样，为什么会这样，我们也许能够开发某些应用，比如
therapeutic applications for people with memory disorders. So that's something that I think is important to research. The short answer that I would give goes back to the reward system because we know that the reward system is central to memory formation. I mentioned at the very beginning that reward is related to reinforcement. So, you know, reinforcement learning goes way back, you know, in psychology, right, to the middle of the previous century. And the idea is that you learn to perform certain actions based on how rewarding they are, which means that you're encoding information, and you're encoding their information, and you're encoding
针对记忆障碍人群的治疗应用。所以这是我认为值得研究的重要课题。我给出的简短回答是回到奖励系统，因为我们知道奖励系统对记忆形成至关重要。我在最开始提到奖励与强化有关。所以，你知道，强化学习可以追溯到，你知道，上个世纪中叶的心理学，对吧？这个想法是，你根据行动的奖励程度来学习执行某些行动，这意味着你正在编码信息，并且你正在编码他们的信息，并且你正在编码
their information better when your dopamine levels are higher and less well when your dopamine levels are lower. And this makes perfect sense from a biological perspective. You want to remember the things that are important, the things that are salient, the things that will bring you reward compared to things that are kind of trivial or unimportant. So it stands to reason that since music does activate the reward system, when you are listening to that music, you're in a state of heightened information processing, which leads to better memory formation. And so that, I think, is part of the reason why we have these sometimes quite strong autobiographical sorts of effects, because typically they're very emotionally salient events
他们的信息，当你的多巴胺水平较高时，编码得更好，而当你的多巴胺水平较低时，编码得较差。从生物学的角度来看，这完全说得通。你想要记住那些重要的事情，那些显著的事情，那些会给你带来奖励的事情，而不是那些琐碎或不重要的事情。所以有理由认为，既然音乐确实激活了奖励系统，当你听那段音乐时，你处于一种增强的信息处理状态，这会导致更好的记忆形成。所以，我认为这就是为什么我们有时会有这些非常强烈的自传体影响的部分原因，因为通常它们也是非常具有情感显著性的事件
as well. So it's the emotion generated by the music, but also the emotion generated by the event. The two together cause an association to to be formed between the music and the event, whatever it is that you're remembering. We're going to take a short break. When we return, I'll talk with Dr. Zatori about what makes music beautiful and whether there are any pieces of music that are considered universally beautiful. I want to talk about what makes music beautiful. Now, if you Google world's most beautiful music, right? Google the source of everything, you get an amazing range of answers. I mean, everything from Barbara Zadagio that I mentioned in the intro to the temptations, My Girl,
一样。所以这是音乐产生的情感，也是事件产生的情感。两者结合在一起导致音乐和事件之间形成了关联，无论你记住的是什么。我们要休息一下。回来后，我将与扎托雷博士讨论是什么让音乐变得美丽，以及是否有任何音乐作品被认为是普遍美丽的。我想谈谈是什么让音乐变得美丽。现在，如果你在谷歌上搜索“世界上最美的音乐”，对吧？谷歌是万物之源，你会得到一系列惊人的答案。我的意思是，从我在介绍中提到的巴伯的《柔板》到诱惑乐队的《我的女孩》，
to the soundtrack for Phantom of the Opera, for example. But aside from the reaction of people who have Anhedonia, are there any pieces of music that are universally considered beautiful? I would say that the answer is no, with respect to the question. to specific pieces of music, I would say the answer is yes, with respect to specific principles that underlie different types of music. So let me unpack that for you a little bit. So music is extremely culturally dependent, right? So when someone says that they like the Beatles, presumably this is someone who grew up in a certain time period, in a certain place, with a certain sort of cultural background.
再到《歌剧魅影》的原声带，等等。但是，除了那些有快感缺失的人的反应之外，有没有任何音乐作品被普遍认为是美丽的？我会说答案是否定的，就特定的音乐作品而言；我会说答案是肯定的，就构成不同类型音乐的特定原则而言。所以让我为你稍微拆解一下。所以音乐是非常依赖文化的，对吧？所以当有人说他们喜欢披头士乐队时，推测这是一个在特定时间、特定地点、具有特定文化背景下成长起来的人。
If you take someone who is, you know, a member of an isolated tribe in the Amazon forest, they have their own music, and it is probably not the Beatles. And if you play the Beatles for them, they'll go, I don't know what that's about, but I prefer my flute and my drum, which are meaningful to me. And this is true, right?
如果你带一个，你知道，亚马逊森林中一个孤立部落的成员，他们有自己的音乐，那可能不是披头士。如果你给他们放披头士的音乐，他们会说，我不知道那是什么，但我更喜欢我的笛子和鼓，它们对我来说是有意义的。这是真的，对吧？
Music is present in all cultures, but differs significantly, at least in its superfluid. superficial expression in terms of the instruments that are used, in terms of the different scales that are used, you know, we're all familiar with the Western scale. People tend to think that's the only one that exists, but it's absolutely not the case. If you listen to Indian classical music, they have Raghaz, which are quite different from the Western ones. If you go to Indonesia, they play gamelans, which have a completely different sound structure to them and so on and so forth for many different cultures. same for rhythms. In Western music, we tend to use duple or triple meters, but there are certain cultures in Africa, for example, that use far more complex metrical structures, you know, meters of seven or 11, sort of prime number metrical structure, which sounds weird to us, and we can't even reproduce it, but they can. So what makes music beautiful? I think there is a universal
音乐存在于所有文化中，但差异显著，至少在其表面的表达上，就所使用的乐器而言，就所使用的不同音阶而言，你知道，我们都熟悉西方音阶。人们倾向于认为那是唯一存在的音阶，但绝对不是这样。如果你听印度古典音乐，他们有拉格，这与西方的非常不同。如果你去印度尼西亚，他们演奏甘美兰，它有一种完全不同的声音结构，以此类推，许多不同的文化都是如此。节奏也是一样。在西方音乐中，我们倾向于使用二拍子或三拍子，但例如在非洲的某些文化中，使用远为复杂的节拍结构，你知道，七拍子或十一拍子，某种质数节拍结构，这对我们来说听起来很奇怪，我们甚至无法重现它，但他们可以。那么是什么让音乐变得美丽？我认为有一个普遍的
feature of what makes music beautiful, irrespective of the culture, and that is the degree to which a particular moment of music is predictable or not. And there's a fundamental principle in psychology, which has been known from the time of Wilhelm Wundt in the 19th century, which is that you need to have a certain degree of surprise to experience something as pleasurable or important or salient, but not too much surprise and not too little surprise. So there's a curve.
让音乐变得美丽的特征，与文化无关，那就是一段音乐在多大程度上是可预测的。心理学中有一个基本原则，从19世纪威廉·冯特的时代起就为人所知，那就是你需要有一定程度的惊喜才能将某事体验为愉悦的、重要的或显著的，但不能太惊喜，也不能太少惊喜。所以有一条曲线。
It's called the Wundt Curb. He published it in 1887, I think. And it's been demonstrated many, many times since. So what does it mean? It means that the brain is constantly trying to interpret what it receives from the environment and trying to anticipate what the next thing will be that's coming. This again goes back to a very fundamental survival mechanism. If you're in an environment and you see a sequence of events,
它被称为冯特曲线。我想他是在1887年发表的。从那以后，它已经被多次证明。那么它意味着什么？这意味着大脑不断地试图解释它从环境中接收到的东西，并试图预测接下来会发生什么。这再次回到了一个非常基本的生存机制。如果你在一个环境中，你看到一系列事件，
you want to be able to know what's going to happen next so that you can be prepared to take the right action. The right action might be to pounce and grab the prey and eat it, or the right action might be to run away as fast as you can, or the right action might be, you know, approach another member of your species, you know, with some proposal for lovemaking or something like that, right? These are all very different actions,
你想要能够知道接下来会发生什么，这样你就可以准备好采取正确的行动。正确的行动可能是扑上去抓住猎物并吃掉它，或者正确的行动可能是尽可能快地逃跑，或者正确的行动可能是，你知道，接近你物种的另一个成员，你知道，带着某种求爱建议或类似的事情，对吧？这些都是非常不同的行动，
but you're always trying to anticipate what's happening. Now, music is kind of a microcosm of that, because music consists of a sequence of elements over time that are unfolding over time, and they follow a certain pattern, depending on your culture. It might be a rhythmic pattern of a certain type, might be a scale structure of a certain type.
但你总是试图预测正在发生的事情。现在，音乐是那种情况的一个缩影，因为音乐由随时间展开的一系列元素组成，它们遵循某种模式，取决于你的文化。它可能是一种特定类型的节奏模式，可能是一种特定类型的音阶结构。
Those differ across cultures, but across all of them, you always have some degree of expectation about what will happen, and the musician knows this implicitly. Every musician who ever talk to, whenever I explain this whole theory, they go, well, yeah, of course, we know this.
那些在不同文化中有所不同，但在所有文化中，你总是对接下来会发生什么有一定的期望，而音乐家含蓄地知道这一点。我交谈过的每一位音乐家，每当我解释整个理论时，他们都会说，嗯，是的，当然，我们知道这一点。
You know, this is what we do. We give you something a little different than what you were expecting. We don't just give you the identical thing, because that's boring. If I play something like a major scale, if I play major scale you know
你知道，这就是我们所做的。我们给你一些与你预期的有点不同的东西。我们不会只给你完全相同的东西，因为那很无聊。如果我演奏像大调音阶这样的东西，如果我演奏大调音阶，你知道
super boring like no one would listen to that why because it's too predictable you know exactly what's going to happen at every moment if I play a bunch of completely random notes complete chaos that's also totally boring
超级无聊，就像没有人会听那样，为什么？因为它太可预测了，你知道每一刻会发生什么。如果我演奏一堆完全随机的音符，完全混乱，那也完全无聊
why because it's also unpredictable there's no structure so you cannot predict what's going to happen but there's a sweet spot that Dilhembund identified which is the balance between predictability and surprise. So you want some surprise,
为什么？因为它也是不可预测的。没有结构，所以你无法预测会发生什么。但威廉·冯特确定了一个最佳点，即在可预测性和惊喜之间的平衡。所以你想要一些惊喜，
but you also need some predictability. In fact, in order to get surprise, you need to have predictability. In order to be surprised, you have to be expecting that something's going to happen. If you're completely lost without knowing what's going on,
但你也需要一些可预测性。事实上，为了获得惊喜，你需要有可预测性。为了感到惊讶，你必须期望会发生某事。如果你完全迷失了，不知道发生了什么，
you can't be surprised because you have no expectation about what's going to happen. So I think this is the key to what makes music and other art forms as well. People have applied this theory to poetry, for example, or to humor.
你就不会感到惊讶，因为你对接下来会发生什么没有任何期望。所以我认为这是让音乐和其他艺术形式变得美丽的秘诀。人们已经将这个理论应用于诗歌，例如，或幽默。
You know, we have some, like the punchline is an unexpected event, even to visual art. People have tried this. And I think that the reward system, coming back to that idea, we know this from experiments. We know that it's extremely sensitive to obtaining rewards that are unexpected. So I mentioned, you know, the classical experiments where you're measuring dopamine from, let's say, a rodent as it receives food.
你知道，我们有一些，比如妙语是一个意想不到的事件，甚至应用于视觉艺术。人们已经尝试过这个。我认为奖励系统，回到那个想法，我们从实验中知道这一点。我们知道它对获得意想不到的奖励极其敏感。所以我提到，你知道，经典的实验，你正在测量多巴胺，比如，一只啮齿动物在它接受食物时。
And sure, there's a response. But what's even more interesting is that you can condition that response on an unrelated stimulus, like, let's say a light goes on, that signals that food will come. And the reward system will, once the animal is trained, will respond to that signal earlier in time. And then if the reward that it receives is larger than usual, you'll get a huge boost in the dopamine response. So this is what a reward system is sensitive to. It's sensitive to the reward you're experiencing in relation to the cues that preceded it,
当然，有反应。但更令人感兴趣的是，你可以将该反应条件反射到一个不相关的刺激上，比如，假设一盏灯亮起，预示着食物会到来。一旦动物被训练，奖励系统就会在时间上更早地对该信号做出反应。然后，如果它收到的奖励比平时大，你会得到多巴胺反应的巨大提升。所以这就是奖励系统所敏感的东西。它对你正在经历的奖励相对于之前预示它的线索敏感，
the cues that predicted it. So if you're following the music and you make a certain prediction, and then the musician plays a different chord that, let's say, modulates into a different key, or there's the entrance of a new voice, for instance, right? You're hearing the bass guitar and then the singer comes in at a certain moment, maybe a slightly unexpected moment. These are the kinds of moments of music that people find super pleasurable, and it can be related back to these very fundamental mechanisms
那些预示它的线索。所以如果你正在跟随音乐，你做出了某种预测，然后音乐家演奏了一个不同的和弦，假设调制到了不同的调，或者有新声音的进入，例如，对吧？你正在听低音吉他，然后歌手在某个时刻进来，也许是一个稍微意想不到的时刻。这些是人们觉得超级愉悦的音乐时刻，它可以追溯到这些非常基本的机制，
where you are surprised. You were expecting something, but what you got was even better than what you were expecting. And that's where dopamine really kicks in and gives you pleasure. I'm wondering if there is a connection between musical ability and language aptitude, since music is an affected type of language. And it's also a type of mathematics. I mean, you can't really play music without having some fundamental intrinsic understanding of math. Do you see these connections neurologically? Yes, no. I think we do see some relationships between these different functions, but not in the way that people usually think about it.
在那里你感到惊讶。你期待着什么，但你得到的甚至比你期待的还要好。这就是多巴胺真正发挥作用并给你带来愉悦的地方。我想知道音乐能力和语言天赋之间是否有联系，因为音乐是一种情感类型的语言。它也是一种数学类型。我的意思是，如果没有对数学的一些基本内在理解，你真的无法演奏音乐。你在神经学上看到这些联系吗？是的，不。我认为我们确实看到了这些不同功能之间的一些关系，但不是人们通常认为的那样。
So a common idea that's out there that people are promoting because they can make money from it is that, oh, well, if you give your kid music lessons, they'll do better in math class. I'm not terribly convinced by the evidence for that. And besides, if your goal is to make the kid be better in math, they should take math lessons, not music lessons. I think music lessons are fantastic because music is fantastic, not because it's good for math. So to me, that's not quite the right thing. Having said that, we do know that there are certain cognitive operations in the brain
所以外面有一个普遍的想法，人们正在推广它，因为他们可以从中赚钱，那就是，哦，嗯，如果你给你的孩子上音乐课，他们在数学课上会表现得更好。我并没有被支持这一点的证据所说服。而且，如果你的目标是让孩子在数学上表现得更好，他们应该上数学课，而不是音乐课。我认为音乐课很棒，因为音乐很棒，而不是因为它对数学有好处。所以对我来说，那不太对。话虽如此，我们确实知道大脑中存在某些认知操作
that are relevant for both music-making. and for something like math. And I'll give you an example. So there's a part of the brain, the parietal lobe, which we know is important for doing sort of what mathematicians would call coordinate transforms. So that could be as simple as recognizing an object when it's in one orientation and then you rotate it to another orientation
这对于音乐制作和像数学这样的事情都是相关的。我会给你一个例子。所以大脑中有一个部分，顶叶，我们知道它对于做数学家所说的坐标变换很重要。所以这可以简单到识别一个物体，当它处于一个方向时，然后你把它旋转到另一个方向，
and you recognize that it's the same object. So this part of the brain is in the parietal lobe is responsible for things like that that we do very automatically intake for granted. You can extend that to actual math. So doing geometry, for instance, or geometric theorems or, I don't know, matrix algebra, there are many aspects of math that would involve similar kinds of computations. It turns out that there are also musical computations. These are implicit computations, right? Like you're not aware of it. Like when you recognize the object in different orientations,
你认出它是同一个物体。所以大脑的这个部分在顶叶中负责我们自动做的事情，并且认为理所当然。你可以把它扩展到实际的数学。所以做几何，例如，或几何定理，或者，我不知道，矩阵代数，有许多数学方面会涉及类似类型的计算。事实证明，也有音乐计算。这些是隐含的计算，对吧？就像你没有意识到它。就像当你识别不同方向的物体时，
you're not thinking to yourself, oh, there's a rotation of 37.6 degrees, which corresponds to this, you know, you just recognize it. Your brain is doing the math. You're not actually, you don't have access, conscious access to those operations. And some years ago, we started thinking, well, what's the musical equivalent of moving an object in space?
你并没有对自己想，哦，有一个37.6度的旋转，这对应于这个，你知道，你只是认出了它。你的大脑正在做数学。你实际上并没有，你没有获得，对这些操作的意识访问。几年前，我们开始思考，嗯，在空间中移动物体的音乐等价物是什么？
And we thought, oh, what's an object? Well, let's say a melody. How do you move it? Well, it doesn't move in space, but it can move in pitch. And musicians call the transposition. Right? This is a very commonplace function that you can recognize the same tune if it's sung in different registers, for instance. right? That doesn't take any special musical training ability. A child can do that without any special training. But if you think about what's going on, think about the pitches of each of the tones, right? If I take, let's say a major chord, C, E, G, right?
我们当时想，哦，什么是对象？嗯，我们说一段旋律。你怎么移动它？嗯，它在空间上不会移动，但它可以在音高上移动。音乐家称之为移调。对吧？这是一个非常普遍的功能，例如，如果你在不同的音域演唱同一首曲子，你也能认出来，对吧？这不需要任何特殊的音乐训练能力。孩子无需任何特殊训练就能做到。但如果你思考一下发生了什么，想想每个音调的音高，对吧？如果我取一个大三和弦，比如 C、E、G，对吧？
If I now transpose it to, I don't know, let's say the key of F-sharp, now it's going to be F-sharp, A-sharp, C-sharp. all the tones are completely different, but you still recognize that the intervals are the same, exactly. The relationships between each pair of tones is the same. Technically, it's the frequency ratios between them. So when we do experiments where we ask people to recognize, this is a major chord or not, in different keys,
如果我现在把它移调到，我不知道，比如升 F 大调，现在它就变成了升 F、升 A、升 C。所有的音调都完全不同，但你仍然能认出它们的音程是完全一样的。每对音调之间的关系是一样的。从技术上讲，这就是它们之间的频率比。所以当我们做实验，要求人们识别这是否是大三和弦，在不同的调式中时，
what we see is that the same region of the parietal lobe is actually active as has been identified for things like visual rotation. And so that's an example of a link between mathematical operations that apply in music and that apply in other domains. And so that I think is kind of a deep similarity between the two. Another area of music that has interested me for a long time is musical autodidacts, the people who become highly proficient at music, but they never really had any formal training. And there are a lot of people on that list. I mean, in popular music, we've got, you know, Jimmy Hendry. Eric Clapton and classical musicians like Edward Elgar, Telemann.
我们看到顶叶的同一区域实际上是活跃的，这与视觉旋转等任务中识别出的区域相同。所以这是一个音乐中应用的数学运算与其他领域应用的数学运算之间联系的例子。我认为这是两者之间的一种深层相似性。音乐中另一个让我长期感兴趣的领域是音乐自学者，那些在音乐上变得非常精通，但从未真正接受过任何正规训练的人。名单上有很多这样的人。我的意思是，在流行音乐中，我们有吉米·亨德里克斯（Jimmy Hendrix）、埃里克·克莱普顿（Eric Clapton），还有像爱德华·埃尔加（Edward Elgar）、泰勒曼（Telemann）这样的古典音乐家。
What is happening in the brains of autodidacts that's different from the rest of us who have to take lessons and practice and practice and never really get great? Yeah, it's a great question. I don't think we know the answer fully, but I think it's a very interesting question because it gets at the issue of individual differences in musical ability. We do see that if you take a random group of, you know, 100 people, you're going to have all kinds of variability in their musical capacities. So, you know, 2% of them might have musical and hedonia.
自学者的大脑中发生了什么，与我们这些必须上课、练习再练习却从未真正变得出色的人有什么不同？是的，这是一个很好的问题。我不认为我们完全知道答案，但我认为这是一个非常有趣的问题，因为它触及了音乐能力个体差异的问题。我们确实发现，如果你随机抽取 100 个人，他们的音乐能力会有各种各样的差异。所以，你知道，其中 2% 的人可能患有音乐快感缺失症。
Another 3 or 4% might have what we call a musia, which is sort of tone deafness. But then another like 5% will just be very, very good at something simple, like sending back a tune. So we all know that there are, like little kids can sing back tunes actually surprisingly well from an early age, but we all know that there are some kids who will not just sing it back, but like sing it back with beautiful ability to shape the tones and to be very, very on pitch and so on. So there's this wide range of abilities out there. Most of us are somewhere in the middle.
另外 3% 或 4% 的人可能患有所谓的失乐症，也就是某种程度上的音盲。但还有 5% 的人会非常非常擅长简单的事情，比如哼唱回旋律。我们都知道，小孩子其实很小就能出奇地好地哼唱回旋律，但我们也知道，有些孩子不仅能哼唱回来，而且能以优美的能力塑造音调，并且非常非常准确地把握音高等等。所以，存在着广泛的能力差异。我们大多数人处于中间水平。
And I think it's very interesting to try to figure out what is going on in the brains of those people who have some kind of innate ability that maybe doesn't require formal training. It probably does require at least some significant exposure. In other words, even if you took, you know, if you took Jimmy Hendricks, you know, when he was born,
我认为试图弄清楚那些拥有某种天生能力、可能不需要正规训练的人的大脑中发生了什么，是非常有趣的。这可能至少需要一些重要的接触。换句话说，即使你带走了，你知道，如果你带走了吉米·亨德里克斯，你知道，当他出生时，
you put him in a place where no music was ever played, he probably would not have developed his ability, right? He must have heard a lot of music in his environment and had the innate capacity to figure out how to play it on an instrument and then how to generate even more new, new things that no one else had ever tried. So what exactly mediates that in the brain? I think it's very much still an open question.
你把他放在一个从未播放过音乐的地方，他可能就不会发展出他的能力，对吧？他一定是在环境中听到了很多音乐，并具备了弄清楚如何在乐器上演奏它的天生能力，然后是如何创造出更多别人从未尝试过的新东西。那么大脑中究竟是什么调节了这一点？我认为这仍然是一个悬而未决的问题。
I would think that it goes back to the connectivity between different parts of the brain. Earlier we talked about the link between the auditory and the motorist systems. I think it's likely that there is variability in that link across a population. Some will have a stronger link. Some will have, most will have a medium link, some will have a very low link. The ones that have that stronger link, it seems logical to me that they might be the ones who, given the right opportunity, would be better able than everyone else to learn how to play an instrument because their auditory system is already highly communicating with the motor system. So they're able to figure out, oh, this sound pattern corresponds to this set of actions on a keyboard. And this set of actions, I know is going to produce that set of sounds because they have the strong link between them.
我认为这可以追溯到大脑不同部分之间的连接性。早些时候我们谈到了听觉系统和运动系统之间的联系。我认为这种联系在人群中很可能存在差异。有些人会有更强的联系。有些人会有，大多数人会有中等的联系，有些人会有非常低的联系。那些拥有更强联系的人，在我看来很合乎逻辑，他们可能是在获得合适的机会时，比其他人更能学会演奏乐器的人，因为他们的听觉系统已经与运动系统高度沟通。所以他们能够弄清楚，哦，这个声音模式对应于键盘上的一组动作。而且我知道这组动作会产生那组声音，因为他们之间有很强的联系。
So that's one example. There are probably many other examples because, again, music is still multifaceted. Some people who are very good at playing an instrument are not necessarily good at other things. Like not every instrumentalist is a gifted composer or songwriter. There are other songwriters who famously were terrible at play. playing anything but could write beautiful songs. I understand Irving Berlin could only play in the key of sea. I think that's right. Yeah, I've heard that story as well.
所以这是一个例子。可能还有许多其他例子，因为音乐仍然是多方面的。有些非常擅长演奏乐器的人不一定擅长其他事情。比如并非每一位器乐演奏家都是天才的作曲家或词曲作者。还有其他著名的词曲作者，他们演奏任何东西都很糟糕，但却能写出优美的歌曲。我知道欧文·柏林（Irving Berlin）只能用 C 大调演奏。我想那是对的。是的，我也听过那个故事。
You know, there's a growing interest in using music in healthcare and rehabilitation for people with dementia, Parkinson's disease, stroke, other kinds of conditions. How do these therapies work? And do you think that basic research on music and cognition will contribute to more of these kinds of applications. Yes, I feel very strongly about this, and I have experience. I've been in this field pretty much from the beginning, going on 45 years now.
你知道，人们对在医疗保健和康复中使用音乐越来越感兴趣，特别是针对痴呆症、帕金森病、中风和其他疾病患者。这些疗法是如何起作用的？你认为关于音乐和认知的基础研究会促成更多这类应用吗？是的，我对此深信不疑，而且我有经验。我几乎从一开始就进入了这个领域，到现在已经快 45 年了。
And I can tell you there's been a dramatic shift in the way that people who work in music therapy respond to the science. So what I've noticed, because I actually am invited to speak to practitioners, you know, clinical practitioners and people who do music therapy, people who do other interventions, they're not necessarily music therapists, but they're using music in some rehabilitative context. And what I find is that those people are finding that the basic science is extremely important because it gives them the foundation
我可以告诉你，从事音乐治疗的人对科学的反应方式发生了巨大的转变。所以我注意到，因为我实际上被邀请向从业者，你知道，临床从业者和从事音乐治疗的人，以及从事其他干预措施的人演讲，他们不一定是音乐治疗师，但他们在某种康复背景下使用音乐。我发现这些人认为基础科学极其重要，因为它为他们提供了基础，
upon which to be able to build their applications. So compared to, you know, 40 years ago, people were doing music therapy, but it was very kind of impressionistic.
使他们能够在此基础上构建他们的应用。所以与 40 年前相比，人们在做音乐治疗，但那是非常印象派的。
They didn't have any, it's not their fault. It's, you know, they were doing the best they could, but they didn't have very much to go on scientifically. But now we do. And, the techniques are becoming much more refined. I'll give you a concrete example.
他们没有任何，这不是他们的错。你知道，他们尽了最大努力，但在科学上他们没有太多依据。但现在我们有了。而且，技术正在变得更加精炼。我给你举一个具体的例子。
There's an NIH-sponsored group called Music for Pain that I'm part of. I think I'm the only Canadian who's somehow part of it. And the goal of this group, it's a large group of people, led mostly by people who do music therapy, and they're very, very interested in developing better techniques for analgesia pain control. via music.
有一个由美国国立卫生研究院（NIH）赞助的名为“音乐止痛”（Music for Pain）的小组，我是其中的一员。我想我是唯一一个以某种方式参与其中的加拿大人。这个小组的目标是一个由很多人组成的大型团体，主要由从事音乐治疗的人领导，他们非常有兴趣开发通过音乐进行镇痛和疼痛控制的更好技术。
And there's already experimental evidence that this can work, but exactly how it works, when it works, why it works, that's still a matter of investigation. And so there's tremendous enthusiasm in that community because they're now starting to be able
而且已经有实验证据表明这是可行的，但它究竟是如何工作的，何时工作，为什么工作，这仍然是一个研究课题。所以那个社区有巨大的热情，因为他们现在开始能够
to say, okay, you know, if you have chronic pain, you can use a certain kind of approach, whereas if you have temporary pain from like somatic pain from an injury, then maybe a different kind of approach would work. So it's really applying the science very directly in clinical settings. And I think that is something that is fairly novel.
说，好的，你知道，如果你有慢性疼痛，你可以使用某种方法，而如果你有来自受伤等躯体疼痛的暂时性疼痛，那么也许另一种方法会有效。所以这确实是在临床环境中非常直接地应用科学。我认为这是相当新颖的。
It's only been in the past five, ten years that's been happening. And I think it's a very, very positive development. it's positive for the practitioners because they're able to bring better techniques to their patients to alleviate their problems. And it's also very good, I think it's very rewarding for me, personally speaking with a reward system. It's very rewarding that after, you know, working on this stuff for 40 years, somebody actually finds it useful. Right? And they come to me and they ask me, you know, well, what about the role of the reward system of this? What about the role of the motor and auditory cortex in that application?
这种情况只发生在过去五到十年里。我认为这是一个非常非常积极的发展。这对从业者来说是积极的，因为他们能够为患者带来更好的技术来缓解他们的问题。而且我认为这对我个人来说也非常有回报，谈论奖励系统。在研究这些东西 40 年后，有人真的觉得它有用，这非常有回报。对吧？他们来问我，你知道，那么奖励系统在其中的作用是什么？运动皮层和听觉皮层在那个应用中的作用是什么？
Like you mentioned Parkinson's, right? That's a lot of the work in Parkinson's to alleviate the motor problems is based on these models that have investigated the link between the auditory and motor systems. And the reward system is very much involved in the pain control idea. So, yeah, I think it's a very very important. promising area. It is still, there's still a lot of work to do. I would say it's still relatively in its infancy. But I think the people working on it are like on the right track. And I think in coming years we'll see more and more and better applications.
就像你提到的帕金森病，对吧？帕金森病中缓解运动问题的很多工作都是基于这些研究了听觉和运动系统之间联系的模型。而奖励系统在疼痛控制理念中非常重要。所以，是的，我认为这是一个非常非常有前途的领域。它仍然，还有很多工作要做。我会说它仍然相对处于起步阶段。但我认为从事这项工作的人走在正确的轨道上。而且我认为在未来几年，我们将看到越来越多更好的应用。
Well, just to wrap up, what are you working on now and what big questions are you trying to answer at the moment? Yeah, we're working on a lot of different things. Some of the stuff we're working on is very hardcore basic science. So we have talked a lot about the auditory cortex, for example. But if you've ever taken a physiology or anatomy course, you know that between the ear and the cortex, there are at least three or four subcortical structures
好吧，最后总结一下，你现在在做什么，目前你试图回答哪些重大问题？是的，我们正在做很多不同的事情。我们正在做的一些事情是非常硬核的基础科学。例如，我们已经谈了很多关于听觉皮层的问题。但如果你曾经上过生理学或解剖学课程，你就知道在耳朵和皮层之间，至少有三到四个皮层下结构
that you have to get through that process sound. So, you know, from the ear, you go to the cochlear nucleus, and then you go to the inferior guluculus, then you go to the medallogeniculate. It's what you learned in first year anatomy class. But until very recently, our brain scanners could not even see those structures because they're quite small.
是你必须通过才能处理声音的。所以，你知道，从耳朵开始，你进入耳蜗核，然后进入下丘，然后进入内侧膝状体。这是你在一年级解剖课上学到的。但直到最近，我们的大脑扫描仪甚至无法看到这些结构，因为它们非常小。
They're very tiny. It doesn't mean they're not important. They're just small, so they're hard to see. So almost all of our theories are about the cortex, even though we know that by the time the sound information gets to the cortex, it's been pre-processed three or four layers. So now we have much higher resolution magnetic resonance imaging devices, which allow us to see these structures, you know, like the inferior caliculus is about the size of the, you know, half of the nail on your little finger, four or five millimeters across.
它们非常微小。这并不意味着它们不重要。它们只是很小，所以很难看到。所以我们几乎所有的理论都是关于皮层的，尽管我们知道当声音信息到达皮层时，它已经被预处理了三到四层。所以现在我们有了分辨率高得多的磁共振成像设备，这使我们能够看到这些结构，你知道，比如下丘的大小大约是，你知道，小指指甲的一半，直径四到五毫米。
But now we can see it. We can actually visualize it. We can measure its activity. So that's very exciting. From a hardcore basic science perspective, we're starting to look at the wiring that underlies that process. And then from a more applied perspective, we're becoming very interested in music and hearing loss. So hearing loss is a huge problem across society. It's extremely prevalent. And it often impacts people's ability to hear speech, of course. That's what everyone focuses on. But it also impacts people's ability to hear music.
但现在我们可以看到它了。我们实际上可以将其可视化。我们可以测量它的活动。所以这非常令人兴奋。从硬核基础科学的角度来看，我们开始研究支撑该过程的布线。然后从更应用的角度来看，我们对音乐和听力损失变得非常感兴趣。所以听力损失是整个社会的一个巨大问题。它非常普遍。当然，它通常会影响人们听取言语的能力。这是每个人都关注的。但它也影响人们听音乐的能力。
and that's much less studied. There are many, many fewer research projects on music as compared to speech. So we're trying to fill that gap a little bit to try to figure out ways to improve music perception. And one of the ways that we're currently working on is, I think, is a fun project, where we're using the tactile sense. So we're using the skin receptors on your hand, which are sensitive to vibration. If you've ever put your hand on any vibrating object, you know that. If you put your hand on the radio when it's playing, you feel vibration, or an instrument.
而这方面的研究要少得多。与言语相比，关于音乐的研究项目要少得多。所以我们正在努力填补这一空白，试图找出改善音乐感知的方法。我们目前正在研究的方法之一，我认为是一个有趣的项目，我们正在使用触觉。所以我们正在使用你手上的皮肤感受器，它们对振动很敏感。如果你曾经把手放在任何振动物体上，你就知道这一点。如果你在收音机播放时把手放在上面，你会感觉到振动，或者乐器。
Indeed. In fact, musicians use vibration. Like if you play a fretless string instrument, like a violin or a cello, the musicians feel the vibration on their fingers. And often, you know, on the violin, they feel it in their neck or in the cello. feel it in their body, and they use that information. So there's a link between vibration and sound, and what we're doing is giving people vibration through a special glove that we have.
确实。事实上，音乐家使用振动。如果你演奏无品弦乐器，比如小提琴或大提琴，音乐家会感觉到手指上的振动。而且通常，你知道，在小提琴上，他们会感觉到脖子上的振动，或者在大提琴上，感觉到身体上的振动，他们会利用这些信息。所以振动和声音之间存在联系，我们正在做的是通过我们拥有的特殊手套给人们提供振动。
So the sound is fed to the ears and to the hand simultaneously. And the idea is that if your hearing is not as good as it was when you were younger, you've lost some amount of hearing. Maybe, just maybe, we can substitute. for some of that via the vibration through your hand. Of course, your hand is intact. Your hand does not have any loss. And so that's one of the exciting things that we're working on.
所以声音同时被传送到耳朵和手上。我们的想法是，如果你的听力不如年轻时那么好，你已经失去了一些听力。也许，仅仅是也许，我们可以通过手上的振动来替代其中的一部分。当然，你的手是完好的。你的手没有任何损失。所以这是我们正在研究的令人兴奋的事情之一。
It's a bit more of an applied question than it is a basic science question. But the two things actually come together because, in fact, what we're realizing is that the subcortical structures that I mentioned that up until now we haven't even been able to measure, are probably involved somehow in the fusion of sounds and vibratory inputs. And so the more we know about the fundamental anatomy physiology and functional properties of the brain, the better able we are to interpret and understand the findings, even of, you know, relatively applied experiments. So I think the two things.
这与其说是一个基础科学问题，不如说是一个应用问题。但这两件事实际上结合在一起了，因为事实上，我们意识到我提到的那些直到现在我们甚至无法测量的皮层下结构，可能以某种方式参与了声音和振动输入的融合。因此，我们对大脑的基本解剖生理学和功能特性了解得越多，我们就越能解释和理解这些发现，即使是相对应用性的实验。所以我认为这两件事。
really go together. You need the basic science. That's the foundation of everything. And the more, the better your understanding is of the basic science, the better able you will be to develop different sorts of applications. Dr. Sotori, I want to thank you for joining me today. It was really a pleasure to be able to talk to you and learn more about the work that you're doing. Thank you. Thank you so much, Kim. You can find previous episodes of Speaking of Psychology on our website, at speaking of psychology.org or on Apple, Spotify, YouTube, or wherever you get your podcasts. And if you like what you've heard, please subscribe and leave us a review. If you have comments or ideas for future podcasts, you can email us at speaking of psychology
确实结合在一起。你需要基础科学。那是所有一切的基础。而且你对基础科学的理解越深入，你就越能开发出各种不同的应用。索托里博士，我要感谢你今天加入我。能够与你交谈并了解你正在做的工作，我真的感到非常荣幸。谢谢。非常感谢你，金。你可以在我们的网站 speakingofpsychology.org 或 Apple、Spotify、YouTube 或任何你获取播客的地方找到《心理学谈话》（Speaking of Psychology）之前的剧集。如果你喜欢你所听到的，请订阅并给我们留下评论。如果你对未来的播客有评论或想法，你可以通过电子邮件发送给我们 speakingofpsychology
at APA.org. Speaking of Psychology is produced by Lee Weinerman. Thank you for listening. For the American Psychological Association, I'm Kim Mills. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
at APA.org。《心理学谈话》由李·韦纳曼（Lee Weinerman）制作。感谢收听。我是美国心理学会的金·米尔斯（Kim Mills）。本集目前还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子即可发表评论。